welcome to this video for round seven of
Tom memorial 2013 and we have ya round
seven as mentioned and this means three
rounds to go and its really heating up
now with the Nakamura in the lead but
he's playing his closest um pursuers um
Gelfond this round round seven and
Carlton on Rhonda in round eight
tomorrow so let's have a look at round
seven and done let's see which game
should we start with let's start with
Mammadyarov against holland and we get
down the slav and here Sammy slav one of
alan's main defenses against Wandy form
for his whole career actually is playing
this for like 25 years so he's got a
huge experience we get him a line of the
end and entire Marin that's usually
caught with Quincy too early yeah here
black has a wider wider range of moves
that you can play one of the main moves
a sound capture to capture actually it's
not quite quite a good alternative and
then let's say six or c5 there are many
ideas black can also play the instant
'if i for i can play a six there's a ton
of moves and in fact unempl 85 which is
some a bit of a shame actually because
e5 leads to the type of game that you
don't really like to see at the
spectator right now captures and place
me for this is some the most testing way
to play white can capture here and get
to an isolated Queen sport position
but the problem is he at the moment like
a threatening to take so probably what
should exchange here the slab problem is
that both the bishop and the Queen are
not positioned well this bishop likes to
be an e2 and possibly f3 to pressurize
the pawn on d3 adjust blocks the d file
and the Queen Elsa to actually isn't so
great as well because then it is quite
likely that black will put this Bishop
somewhere not quite sure where and then
rook c8 and then the queen is on a bad
failure so this is not such a great
isolated pawn position in white place
you form now this now leads to mess
exchanges in the center takes takes here
yeah in fact if white would capture here
black gum has more than one good move
this is this is one of them yeah
something like this and now the problem
is if white retreats then there's this
tactic winning a pawn white capturing
rd5 is actually the the best businesses
been established but it also is a kind
of position where like it's in in quite
decent shape because he's so active with
Queen edge for greenish was actually
much better than they're taking yet this
is also a typical idea but in this
position after let's say root g one lop
the only move but a good one and it's
simply that white has got two bishops in
an open position and the deep ball and
then what he played this is actually
stronger threatening made threatening
the night it needs to retreat and then
queen age five this is just much more
active black now intends to simply grab
d5 possibly after some preparation or
right to be six and then take it and if
this is exchanged and there's nothing
concrete for what it's just very
raj maria of plate and this this way
which is also known here the black
simply exchanges herder because he is
hoping that he will get the d5 pawn
anyway and probably this hope is
justified you treated now and just be
six if you would take now oops not this
arrow group do you want is quite a
problem it's not losing immediately but
it leads to big trouble something like
this you can actually try to make work
because of this trick but why does some
is better anyway came just be six he
wants to take the porn well and in fact
it seems that black has excellent
chances to simplify this to a dead draw
in the game you see that this happened
and why it has a very slight temporary
initiative I think they would have
stopped the game immediately if black
now would have the pony on b7 that you
could play Bishop to b6 for example then
they would draw just just immediately
because there's absolutely zero here
White has slight hopes because of this
weakness on g6 it's the dead but it's at
least something getting a night to do
you to see six but but it's just a
matter of a couple of precise moves to
prevent that now the bishop comes to be
six and this is just a couple of checks
really the king is safe on g6 on look c6
as played here they're simply f6 and no
progress whatsoever
after some mumbles infer the exchanges
now this is a little trick but it's not
winning a poem at the end White gets it
back here they agreed a draw on move 40
yes this is this line with woody five is
some in fact a slight problem for what
if you fight for you want to fight for
something in this line if I've as is
causing you some trouble the set up with
Bishop to d3 instead of hoops Bishop to
e2 in fact them we just go to this just
hear what can also play this smooth and
after this 'if I've is a different
position simply because here there are
moves like rock do you want for example
and do it simply have a better piece set
up to combat the isolated pawn this is
not possible with the bishop on d3 but
the bishop on d3 has some other points
but Bishop d3 e5 is a very principled
way for black to just try to kill the
game and just make an instant wrong
which is not too attractive to watch but
if you need to draw with black it's a
good line okay let's go to kayaking
koala onyx and I must say I will go
through this rather quickly because this
game is unbelievably long we have a root
Spanish opening and oh sorry like it's
some playing the typical moves here for
the marshal but kayaking is not allowing
it is playing a four can one answered
this was be4 this is nowadays the most
popular reply against a four and it
seems that black isn't in
much trouble now if five this is
important before night c4 has played
black place this move himself winning a
temple white wants to preserve the
bishop and after c5 black has managed to
make use of the sea porn which is very
important quite often this setup is
problematic in the rip on you 45
openings in general because this knight
on c6 isn't such a great piece anyway
you often like to regroup it like in the
Briar you bit this way or get it to the
King side and you would like to use the
C porn it's blocked at the moment and
this is why Knight a5 and c5 such a
popular maneuver like in the chi Goran
light for example black gets the C porn
working immediately we see in this game
that here he quickly gets to play f4 and
i would like to advance a couple of
moves to get to a certain structure
black it's trying to get the a5 form and
he does but white gets the a6 palm yeah
I was some aiming at to this structure
this is a structure that favors white
the only question is how much it favors
white because some his paw structures
somewhat stronger c5 is a possible
weakness and also d5 so white has
chances to use those square as those
weaknesses all those squares a week
while why it has no such a weakness what
what black can try to do is 96 to f4 is
one idea but why do I will always have
nasty position pieces we see the bishop
is very strong it's always putting some
pressure against the f7
and yeah here's blacks counter play with
the light until white I keep hitting
this bloody button why just takes it
this night after capturing on c4d takes
if he plays he five and six we are not
if not immediately sorry rugby want to
be sadness the first I get black
immediately goes for counter play white
cannot take now because there's a count
of right against p1 so rookie one back
rook e8 andy sixx this is what I was
getting at why this has reached the Sun
position where this rook has a very
annoying pin on this bishop the bishop
cannot move because rook e8 hangs so
black has a problem here he cannot
really avoid to get into exactly this
position here no Mazel petition and now
queen d 5 so this is the problem White
has the more active pieces and he's got
the better piece for this structure this
Bishop is really limited it's limited by
the spawn and of course there's always
this pinning issue in addition white of
course threatens to use his night very
effectively with them something about 95
for example g6 and rookie won the
problem is if you go 95 there's some
loops this check yeah this kind of stuff
is just a perpetual this is why you drop
back to one it doesn't really change
much in terms of the other structure
it really looks shaky but I checked this
with the combat seems that white doesn't
have a win getting out of checks and
back to e8 okay yeah this is in fact a
very very young thankless task for black
to play this position you can only
defend passively Kara wanna is really
doing a great job I mean this is a
position where you have very good losing
chances against a strong player simply
because he will spin it round and round
and round and try all kinds of things
but like you can only defend all the
time in fact what white would love to do
is to somehow play night at 325 but it's
not so easy to do in fact why does a try
for that but it doesn't manage we see
this a couple of moves later with this
this is a possible idea like here here
here or this this kind of route right
Queen to g5 Queenie 6 in fact exchanging
isn't so great something like this it's
still ugly looking but you probably
won't win this game with white 26 is
better Queen at five Quincy 6 and Queen
to f7 yep black can just stay there's no
way to really improve things only a
couple of books later here whoop dat is
an interesting moment Queen c7 and now
Bishop to f6 this is very interesting
black also um certainly do you thought
about Ruby aid but after Queen to d7
it's difficult now to make a move
there's 95 also coming in 5c 685 g6 very
very problematic blacks losing here but
black has another idea and he's just
playing Bishop to f6 this is very strong
it simply gives up the pawn white can
just take c5 and he did at least there's
a pawn now for white but I still think
this is a very good defensive maneuver
because black now really activates his
pace position grouped to d7 Andrew could
be seven now black managers blockade of
the pond the bishop is some limiting the
night and black has this c4 pawn that he
can attack while white is hard-pressed
to make any advantage and any advance
I'm sorry in fact black is trying to get
some play on the kingside traditional
play here I think he simply calculated
this does end game and saw beforehand
that he will always get this well known
and game Brooke against look at night
and this is really completely dead I
mean rook bishop against Lucas a
slightly tricky especially with little
time but against the night you really
need to make multiple mistakes too to
lose or really a big one like blundering
the the piece well they played this for
a while I'm not even sure how many moves
is really not a big gum a big deal
shouldn't analyze this now it ended in a
draw is the second I can tell you don't
know how many moves it's really a lot
when 140 something there
there is a natural end to this because
of the 50 movie with the night it's
really pointless you cannot really make
anything out of this yeah yeah probably
they played it all the way through no no
he has a draw very long game yeah and
the game where of course kayaking was
always yeah pushing something like this
is really a a good position for white
and very difficult and and then
requiring lots of lots of tough
defending skills to do to really hold it
not to lose very good job by Caruana
yeah a draw after all yeah let's check
carlton against me Rosie which cars are
certainly with white getting close to
the end of the tournament must try to
win against merasa virtue is not an
exactly great shape and we see a cow
come on the board and more pleasant
night to disabilities the old the
somewhat old-fashioned is not not fair
description this this has been in
fashion starting from the late 80s
because Karpov was playing it with lots
of success following here with Knight to
f6 nowadays Bishop f5 is by far the
Mabel's this always has been the main
move really even back from the 70s but
Bishop 97 was and then quite some wasn't
fashion for a long time okay but now
morrow is playing it and it is some
actually quite young widely known
established whatever that White's try
for an edge mostly is connected with the
move 95 which looks a bit strange to be
honest but it has some points one sneaky
point is that h6 is answered
by 926 this actually happened to me once
in a blitz game I will always remember
that because with black gap with black
young I didn't know this trick and when
I was the kid really and this guy played
this against me in a blitz game and I
was totally shocked um yeah it it leads
to a nice position for white something
like I don't know the check our queen to
be six black needs to move the queen of
course and then why just takes yeah it
has a position way it just enjoys the
two bishops it's not lost or anything
but it just it's just a nice exchange
and those this piece isn't so great okay
but Carlo plates III which is pretty
much unknown I didn't know this move at
least nine f6 and now he took and played
Bishop d3 okay I see that he probably
wants to UM make it difficult for black
to play a Bishop to g4 let's say if you
play Knight f3 Bishop g4 is probably
already equal it's very hard to believe
that this should be anything for white
after h3 black can you take and play a
move like a queen d 5 and this is really
nothing the structure it's the two
bishops but black is so solid it's very
hard to make anything out of this yeah
but cows and play Bishop to d3
preventing Bishop f5 and Bishop g4 I
mean it's a bit into thin air so this
isn't so great but morale just played
Queen to d5 and this looks quite good
it's attacking this pawn and also
prepares Bishop to f5 so if white plays
the simple move like this black can't
decide between Bishop g4 or Bishop f5
and both looks like it's nothing great
for white he played f3 you should f5
and 92 okay this is once again one of
those openings where cards and willem is
playing in a very non theoretical
fashion and just tries to play a game
but look at this yeah it's a small
temple why it takes no 95 black just
wants to exchange pieces and and get a
draw but it's a it's not a bad thing to
draw again the world number one g3 white
plate is six and now black just took
here and Queen g5 so after 14 moves what
is this it's just completely equal
morrow has equalized them very easily
actually you got rid of a couple of
pieces you can always play on check the
move Bishop to b6 sometimes it can be
tricky but this is one one thing black
might even castle on and in the game
after this here black gum got this
moving and F has absolutely no problems
we see that materials completely equal
and it's also a completely symmetrical
pawn structure in terms of majorities
three again three on blog on both sides
and unless there is something
extraordinarily happening and in a
technical way then this is just very dry
and in fact after a couple of moves
check check
I didn't even know that they played this
out so long okay now i remember you've
got a queen trade even and now this is
just dead wrong yeah okay black doesn't
even need to be cautious I mean just
just dead Quinn side is closed and now
we have some porn [ __ ] and after age
six draw was was agreed so in fact 47
moves but the odds also as you can see
from morals time spent it was a very
easy to offer and once in a while I'm
really not sure what cutter is doing at
the opening I mean this looks like
really absolutely nothing I understand
that he only wants those kind of
playable let's get a game position so
he's not the kind of person like let's
say to Paula for Kasparov who wants to
really a had those very deep technical
opening breath to get a sort of let's
say I'm if you compared to tennis it's a
kind of serve and volley approach try to
really serve very hard and win with the
first volley within 25 moves something
like that this is not Carlton's game but
sometimes he plays the opening so let's
say and then somewhat unsophisticated
fashion and hope I'm not choosing the
words to make it sound too disrespectful
but it sounds it's so easy for black
tool to get an equal game like here I
mean this is 444 top GM with really so
easy to draw
it's just very hard to make any mistakes
for black I don't know maybe you also
confuse something it's possible
sometimes they have some prep but
somehow get lost in and actually playing
it alright so just to draw and certainly
a game the cousin um had some higher
hopes to get near the top of the table
okay a next game let's check kramnik and
Drake in a Russian duel and in fact we
have we have four Russians in the
tournament right Kramnik and Drake in
kayaking and moral right for Russians
and they haven't scored a single one yet
after six volts which is quite
remarkable statistical feed okay let's
see what happen to a chronic playing is
some usual default list is playing a
closed opening no deform and unmaking
goes for the bow go again with the
exchange he had played a similar line
before against um sis gelfand a nerd
culture early and the tournament he had
played a similar idea and it was against
Galvan burger from play tonight d to
right no I get it right but he played
the Bogle in fact this Bishop before
line and on Bishop d2 to simply exchange
is one of the most solid lines in her or
chess I think it has been championed by
Swedish endgame legend with Amazon and
he has played this like dozens of times
and really rarely ever lost the game he
lost against the cap off one game but he
drew lots of games and this is also
landed cards and has played term quite a
number of times the idea of this
exchange on d to actually is to get a
good post for the Queen on his heaven
quite often we have a problem in those
slightly passive from Queens gambit
positions that you don't know where to
put the Queen only seven you often have
the bishop and seven is actually quite a
good square because quite um
quite typical for later structures is
that the C&D file get opened you have
some exchanges here and then the Queen
on his happen is actually well-placed
because it's not in the the line of
higher of any rooks so black plays for
us this and now Queenie seven as
mentioned now queen III this is some
interesting one idea is to use the queen
of the third rank but it's also
preventing the instant e65 move yeah
Black Knight talk and head 95 the idea
is some to still play five but first of
course ask the Queen where do you want
to go if white a white plate now Queen
to a3 which is okay certainly where else
if you go to see one for example there's
the instant five and this can easily
need to UM a complete equality something
like this is really mm-hmm I'm sorry not
to inspiring for white it's very draws
one point is that these some ponds
really do a good job blocking the bishop
yeah kramnik played Queen III which is
not a bad move I mean you get the Queen
soft and in the meantime you have the
time to play before so it's a position
where certainly if you look at this a
five wins some room on the queenside get
to a position where like here
let's look at this this position we get
a position where wide has a four against
three on the Kings side and black has
got three against two so it the game
here is dictated by this zone by these
structures why it usually tries to
advance his majority while trying to
freeze black smoke black ones so that
black cannot easily move the spawns and
heck this is some also want to make this
position slightly more comfortable for
Wyatt I believe black has a hard time to
move any of those pawns I mean you
hardly can play this one for example
because you we can be five d5 and
everything besides the fact that the
blunders upon I mean black can really
cannot even after preparation with any
of those pawns well wyd can't play a
five a 3g for it's just easier but ok
let's see what happens playgroup to the
eight making it possible to develop the
bishop in three boob tool and Bishop b6
so black has a solid position no doubt
about that I mean I'm not saying that
black is in big trouble I just added the
structure actually should favor white
very slightly not significantly but it
should be a shade better for white but
in fact in this position here it's not
so easy to make a concrete plan from
league first made some slides prep moves
at King to f2 my day for black has got
some counter play look to c 2 and Knight
to d7 so what should white play now I
think we have the right range of
possible moves one good move is 94 for
example I can put it on the board or you
can also play g-form trying to mobilize
your pawns but in fact here chrome leak
at 27 minutes
the clock against and raking with eight
minutes here chronic played the move
King to III and this is really one of
them um yeah worst blunders that it
probably has has made and quite a long
time because this move is quite easily
refuted by simple sequence of moves
black plays Bishop b3 really curious
what he overlooked here I'm saying
because it's really simple to see I'm
not saying that that I wouldn't play
nonsense moves once in a while but but
it's kramnik I mean he's very good
calculator and the problem with this
King III is simply look at this this is
what what black plate this ruckus detect
it cannot go here it cannot go anywhere
just to see one this was played and then
not to be 6 and this is not a
spectacular moves and this is already
over night c4 check is simply come it's
just deadly you have no way to to keep
this together this position not c4 it's
a big thread and the exchange of this
rook also means that B 2 is falling and
in fact King III years it's really a
double ? move because black is winnings
straight away now there's absolutely no
way to to not lose him for instance if
right would exchange rook takes there's
still this threat but also the capture
and there's absolutely no way to defend
it it's just lost white loses the hawk
you inside in the game Kramnik played
rook to deform but now c5 was was just
good a good concrete move to convey
eight and now black is invading with all
his pieces and wins the whole Queen side
yeah Kramnik is continuing a bit but
this is this is quite a mighty force
it's really just a couple of moves
probably because there was a little time
left but just in a couple moves here
here he actually resigned and this means
this scrum legs third loss in this
tournament he hasn't won a game and he's
on on last place long so in last place
for chronic really amazing this must be
the worst tournament probably if I'm not
quite sure since the mid-2000s probably
when he was having some some more
serious health problems and really had a
big rating drop and but you gained
everything it was actually playing them
probably the best chance of his career
close to that at least them may be
compared to 2020 because / off when he
just a couple of month ago was very
close to being the challenge again
against honored and he also played
excellently in the London chest Kasich's
but he's just in a disastrous form him
overlooking this here with King III just
blundering against this Bishop b3 and 9
p-6 own trick must really tricky admits
it's just I don't know sometimes you
really in a are in bad shape okay but
let's go to the final game of this
presentation and this is some the game
between nakamura leading the tournament
with the plus three before this round
against Kelvin to the funny thing by the
way is that Nakamura has from the first
six rounds he had played three White's
three blacks and he won all three black
games and with whitey just just got
fifty percent okay so let's see what
he's doing him with wide against them
Galvan
got infected opens a Solian so Nakamura
is willing to better the distraction
cough not many people nowadays are
willing to do that this resnikoff has an
excellent theoretical status at the
moment and what very often play some
especially the the Russell emo okay we
got refreshing cough and this is the
absolute main line of the rational Cove
and of course continues much longer here
white has the principal choice between
night to d5 and Bishop takes f6 Nakamura
actually played Bishop f6 this is a
sharp of move now hd5 Bishop to e7 take
stakes and now yeah c4 is pop she
removes of recent times but white can
also just play c3 the classical line
very slowly maneuvers but black is in
very a decent shape here theoretically
Knight f6 Bishop f6 sorry this is some
sharper simply because here black
recaptures with the porn you cannot
really take with the Queen it's it's a
bad news this I think is it's the
problem like has a hard time now and not
to lose materia here on the queenside or
get to a very weakened position you
don't really want to take him this is
quite terrible but ok GTX f is is the
idea anyway because now officer 95 like
is playing f5 using the F porn
immediately getting rid of the double
porn and black even has to wear porn so
after fa di exchange there's a second
def porn to replace the the first one
this is a very well-known theoretical
position one of the absolute main
positions of this opening and in fact um
the camera now played a very rare line
he played c4 um this is some rather
normal idea and some other lines where
this double porn is not on the board but
here it is really rare i only found like
it doesn't eat game so many 20 games and
we very quickly get to an original
position like not cooking form and no
nakamura goes for g3 Bishop g2 to regain
the pawn black hair not really keep it
if you try to let's say with this here
just for argument's sake then there's
this move which is really a problem
because Luke c8 Bishop e3 as an instant
loss black cannot really keep the e4
pawn he just played the standard kind of
moves returning the pole playing rugby 8
to get out of the long diagonal and to
cover the spawn and now played f5 and
before this is really a standard fans
resnikoff before I suppose that many
players who are not familiar with this
opening maybe we'll have trouble with um
or let's say trouble playing it because
before it gives up those squares not III
necessarily but with free if you don't
play this pawn then after a letter here
let's for example black can play a form
this is why this um II for move by
girlfriend gives up gives up III as i
call it because now both nights have
really excellent ghosts but what is the
positive side of this move of course it
has one and
it is of course that this Bishop is
exceptionally strong this night gets a
good square and this Bishop is limited
so if all in fact is a good move at at
some according to the positional demands
this move but it's also nothing special
yet so Ruby one is played here white
could actually think about just giving
up the exchange it's a possible idea
black takes it for example wyd still has
got those very nice night out posts and
probably it's not quite enough for an
exchange but it's also not the terrible
idea you play chess rupee one which
after Queen a5 is a temporary phone sec
White has no way to protect the airport
so after castles create to let God upon
but now why it has met the good news he
retreated this night and attacked the d6
bond and in fact it is quite difficult
to to to cover this pawn how I should
like try that if you cover like this
there's this coming and of course this
is threatening anyway so black is
covering the square but gives away g6 in
the process so on how to assess this
position I think it's probably around
equal Black has got two bishops always
nice but white has got nicely
coordinated pieces and he's got them the
only passport at the moment so it
probably should should help cancel each
other out I think it should be around
equal in the game we have six books
played attacking the Queen we treated
and Queenie five like of course doesn't
mind a queen trade his king is
potentially the worst
one it's got less porn cover and in the
end came the bishops should be a big
factor we got the trade and now 95 white
obviously has got a night for a bishop
but this is not a bad piece of course
and the night takes he took upon but it
seems like after that after a five-night
back and Ruby seven white has some a
hard time to to protect the pond and I
think and this is obviously a
computer-supported move that rugby to d1
here is a good good defense y term needs
to be a bit careful the problem is if
you for instance just lose b3 without
any direct um compensation for that
you're not a porn down but it's equal
material but then the a pond is impaired
and supported by this bishop this pawn
is extremely strong so why it needs to
be cautious he cannot give up this porn
for nothing you need some idea and this
this was played I mean this move has got
the idea of black takes now then this
night is having check kings and the
capture and this probably would secure
relatively painless draw 93 Bishop e3
coming this is opposite colored bishops
now the drawing margin is pretty big he
played a knight's e2 e3 though and this
is now a bit of it's now a bit a bit
true trolling for white in fact girl
from played Knight to c6 it seems that a
four was even stronger much stronger
actually but this is the the kind of
move that you can play with very very
much I mean lots of
the clock or if your computer simply
because it's not at all easy to to
calculate it is a good move because of
before and we should be six this is the
big point the point is that black now
threatens Knight takes e4 breaking up
the pawns and here and white doesn't
really have a great move it's really a
weird position the computer gives black
a substantial advantage was more than a
pawn so there must be something but it's
really hard to to figure out what the
problem is at the end it's probably a
case of white not being able to keep the
material together needing to return upon
and then you're playing against the
bishops without any calm the airport is
of course very dangerous as well as well
the computer line for example is rook d1
here a 3 on let me look it up a 3 Bishop
h3 look to f8 covering this c5a to and
black has a clear advantage ninety to
ninety six intending to take on d5 take
on before and at the end promote this is
really lost now I mean you can this is
even analytically understandable but to
see this a formal some here I mean Gavin
obviously saw the movie did consider it
it's clear but to calculate this and
assess this and better for you it's
really a bit of a tug a difficult task
but 96 it's not a bad move it just
doesn't seem to keep that big begin
advantage c5 black gets the poor bag of
course this wasn't possible to keep it
and now Knight b6 and I think this is a
slight mistake a dumb helps black a bit
here um he could have played a rather
thin matic
sequence of moves and this is what I was
getting at this is a look that you need
to be um yeah try to remember that quite
often this can be a good idea if you got
a bishop on g2 that is just biting on
this e4 pawn and this g5 can be a very
good way to to make something of you of
your piece on g2 here black actually
needs to take that's not much else and
after Bishop before this Bishop is
really playing a good role now in the
game being on this centralized post I
think this was easier after Knight b6
and here the exchange and then black
black is already the one pushing because
um yeah what can you say this they are
something but it's still not the end of
the world but um couple of time travel
moves and here nakamura need 35 they
both had that decent enough time left
here now camera William played the
blunder get a night to a form the
problem with this move is that black has
a good direct move and if you like you
can pause the video and try to find it I
would quite a couple of seconds now
alright so it is III very strong white
has no choice cannot move the porn you
need to take it okay okay and now we see
what's happening this King it's in a
crossfire of the bishops needs to go to
a Sri and this now after the trade is
excellent for black simply because this
King is just such a yeah it's just a
very endangered here I mean just a block
this kind of stuff oops okay not that
fun like this is check her but it can
easily be be a checkmate very quickly if
white plays a nothing move I'm not quite
sure what nothing moves us here like
this for example is away c5 it's not so
easy to make a nothing booth this one
def maybe this one then that g4s is
really winning almost this him they're
white played 93 and Bishop f3 I think
it's really lost now allowing this III
am moved was was giving the game away
and here it is lost in fact there are
many ways now to make progress this in
fact is a main threat even with Bishop
g5 made at the end so let's say that's a
hear ya for example 94 what are you
doing now you just want to put this made
on the bottle quite nice this is the
threat now and white really has no way
to defend this there's nothing okay I
forgot one thing instead of nights see
396 was some good tougher but it's
already half million
really awful to play this is some
relatively best line but you can you can
look at this okay something like this is
some is coming up after after Knight b6
on 240 and this is of course I'm just
terrible to flaming look at this is
dominated this Bishop is dominating this
night and this pawn you got the space
advantage the king is still in trouble
slide trouble yeah black is clearly
better here as well but it's probably
not immediately winning after Knight c3
Bishop every it's already a like if you
want to go to computer terms that minus
4 or something and after Bishop e2 this
little exchange maneuver Knight g4 is
just exceptionally strong the problem is
after night XG for that this is quite a
nice mate so this was played Knight
takes ok white gets gets a beast back
but I not even I'm sorry oops after this
if nakamura resigned Nazi for the only
continuation also what is this and now
black will get the porn and win with
this person so an excellent win for
galfar to plate very precisely I mean he
didn't make any sort of mistake in this
game well my camera allowed this III
move which really opened up the position
in blacks favor if my camera with voided
night a4 he probably would have had
quite um quite good chances to to draw
this position it's not nice to play but
probably still a draw
so Gavin's taking the lead the oldest
participant with he's 44 45 I think 44
years old and he's playing the best
chess ever that he played so he's I
don't know to 770 or something now which
is really amazing so the Drina shows
that even if you're in your forties you
can still improve and but of course a
bad day for Nakamura who with three wins
is black with white now a song on minus
one and yeah it was simply wasn't such a
great position to play maybe not the
best best preparation I would say that I
have a slight problem 22 to point out a
wide set up here because i only have
some experience of this opening with
black I always liked black because you
have pawns in the center you have two
bishops you have a safe King White has
got positional ideas you can sum squares
of course for his pieces but it's
looking like like this squares oops
sorry fyd three I mean but they always
liked black because yeah well Hammond I
will bishop pair edict and I like pawns
in the center so I always liked black
more in these positions which is a
personal preference long an objective
assessment alright so after this round
Gelfond in the lead followed by Nakamura
and after that there's cards and
unshaken and mama y are off and we've
got Carlton against Nakamura tomorrow
maybe in the current state of affairs
lucka has a better off with black half
the three black wins at Goro but anyway
this is Gardens a big chance to get
something going in the tournament he
really needs to win with white he needed
to win today as well and played
a non game against Morrow but you never
know maybe also wasn't feeling too well
I don't really know okay so um thanks
for for watching and listening I'll be
back with round eight coverage tomorrow
thanks and bye